we have new job numbers and they're
they're pretty ugly quite frankly so
before the start of the corona virus
pandemic the u.s. had about a hundred
and fifty eight million people working
now you probably have heard Republicans
bragging about how more people were
working before the corona virus pandemic
than ever before and that's true but
also more people were not working before
the corona virus pandemic than ever
before this is a very popular political
football that I want to remind you of
before we move on to the data which is
the u.s. population grows so if you have
roughly the same portion of the
population working and not working at
almost any point in time you can
accurately say we have more people than
ever working or you can accurately say
we have more people than ever not
working both are often true because the
population keeps getting bigger when
it's a Democratic president the
Republicans focus on the number of
people not working when it's a
Republican president they focus on the
number of people working it's a
meaningless statistic absent population
growth of sort of rates and that is
where that talking point comes from but
needless to say a hundred and fifty
eight million people were working prior
to the start of the corona virus
pandemic we now have a total of at least
twenty two point three million people
who have lost their jobs today we
learned that another five and a quarter
million people filed for unemployment
benefits last week we get the data on a
one-week delay so today we learned about
the numbers from last week this brings
the total to about 21 million people who
have filed for unemployment benefits
since the start of the corona virus
pandemic this is 13 percent of the
working population that have lost their
jobs and the the real number is even
higher and what I mean by that is there
are systems at the state level for
filing for unemployment benefits that
are over the max they are stretched they
are overwhelmed phone systems where it's
just busy they can't even put you in the
hold queue web systems that are just
crashing because of the number of people
trying to file benefits so this is the
number of people that have been able to
file benefit
you've got all the people who have tried
but failed you also have people working
in under the table jobs who do not
qualify for an employment unemployment
benefits traditionally even if
exceptions have been made so that they
do in this particular case many of them
don't know it and they've simply lost
their jobs and not even filed so the
real rate is much higher now we have a
situation where the unemployment rate as
we typically see it this is called the
u3 rate it's going to be almost useless
very soon and I'll explain why the u3 is
going to go up because tens of millions
of people have lost their jobs but it's
likely to go up only a fraction of the
sort of real unemployment rate for this
reason and it's counterintuitive you
might think if thirteen percent of the
workforce lost its job how is it that
the unemployment rate might only go from
like 4 to 6 or 4 to 7 percent it doesn't
make sense the way our system works the
u3 which is that rate that is publicized
though it's 3.8 it's 4.2 when you aren't
looking for work you are no longer
considered unemployed from the purposes
of the unemployment rate this has always
been the case and you know during Obama
as usual as the unemployment rate went
down you had Republicans say the system
is bogus if you stop looking for work
you're no longer considered unemployed
that's been the case for decades so
again it's another distraction technique
that the right loves to use but in this
particular very special situation there
are going to be millions of people who
have just lost their jobs who are not
looking for work because normally when
you file for benefits you have a
questionnaire to fill out or you might
be doing it online you might be
answering it on the phone and you are
asked are you looking for work have you
interviewed anywhere for work give us a
list of where you have and you need to
do that in order to get benefits if you
don't say that you're doing that you
don't get the benefits because so many
of the current job losses are pandemic
related job losses that is not required
you are not required to be looking for
work you're only required to be keeping
in touch with your employer so this
could create a very confusing situation
where despite 22 million people
21 million people losing their jobs we
may only see a couple point uptick in
the official unemployment rate because
that's the way the unemployment rate is
calculated Republicans would complain
about this during Obama's term they'd
say the economy is much worse than the
rate tells you because all these people
are so sick of looking for work in this
terrible Obama economy which wasn't true
that they've stopped looking and so
really the the the u3 is inaccurately
low that's true but that's always the
case here this really matters because
you are not required to be looking for
work to receive unemployment benefits
and then there's the issue of the real
number is way higher over whelmed
unemployment systems as I mentioned
people trying to file claims but unable
to people who have lost jobs where they
traditionally don't get unemployment
benefits so the true number sadly is way
higher than 21 million people now in
real terms how many of these 21 million
jobs are going to reappear as the
pandemic starts to fade the answer is we
don't know number one when we talk about
the pandemic fading there's not going to
be one day where we flip a switch it's
going to be a process it's a process
that could take up to 18 months in some
ways shapes or forms one report said for
restaurants for example July is going to
be the limit for a lot of restaurants at
which point many restaurant owners will
just start walking away from their
leases and not planning to reopen really
really sad because yesterday was the
record death rate a number of deaths
rather in both the United States and
globally so we are not exactly at a time
where we should be planning to reopen
despite Donald Trump announcing
yesterday that today he would give a
list of states that he wants to see
reopen right away one other data point
just out of a curiosity we did a survey
of our own audience and we asked has
your income decreased due to coronavirus
almost 2/3 of our audience says they are
their income is the same or higher
during the virus 11% saw their income
decrease anywhere from 10 to 30 percent
nine percent said their income is down
40 to 70 percent three percent said
their income is down 80 to 90 percent
but 14% of our viewers and listeners say
their income dropped to zero notice that
14% of our audience has lost all their
income
it looks like 13% of the workforce
nationally has gone on unemployment
benefits so very similar numbers numbers
tracking very similarly there so we've
got a big uphill battle to get back to
where we were
industries may change discussions of
nationalizing certain supply chains are
already starting whether it's masks or
medical equipment or whatever because of
the virus anybody pretending to know
what the economic landscape is going to
look like in 18 months is simply
guessing and we need to understand that
we need to sit with the uncertainty
because we really don't have another
choice there's a YouTube channel called
up flip that we're partnering with I
would love for you to check it out I've
put the link right underneath the video
make sure to subscribe to the channel
when you're there up flip is a channel
that is all about exploring small
business and what makes a small business
successful every episode interviews an
entrepreneur you take a tour of the
business and these are not generic
interviews you actually get a really
fascinating deep dive into the history
of the business the mistakes the
entrepreneur made what they learned what
motivates them what a day is like
running their business and you get all
sorts of super interesting and valuable
insight about what it's like to run that
type of small business as a business
owner myself I find up flips videos to
be endlessly intriguing even if you
don't own your own business it is really
great for a general audience it's stuff
that I think just about anybody would
find fascinating and you can check it
out by going to david pakman.com slash
up flip the link is right underneath
this video when you're there make sure
to subscribe and click the bell for
notifications